Salam alaikum guys now this is a very
interesting story check it out a 200
pound bomb sat in the basement of this
Rockland County home according to the
FBI
56 year old Paul Rosenfeld planned to
drive the explosive device to the
National Mall in Washington DC and blow
himself up with it on Election Day I
think one off it would have made a hell
of a mess that's what 200 pounds is a
lot of explosives could have killed a
lot of people take another love you know
most of this block I would say it's
another great example of the clear
double standards and hypocrisy within
the media notice a few things number one
not much media coverage at all mainly
local it's not the 24/7 wall-to-wall
international media coverage where it
becomes the talk of the world like in
the case if the madman lunatic happened
to somehow anyhow be connected to being
a Muslim what do you think would have
happened next number two it's covered as
New York man no mention of the word
terrorists in front of his name many
reports not even showing his picture no
details of his identity or life nor the
mention of his religion now they could
have easily connected it back if they
wanted to a religion they could have
checked if he was baptized if he went to
a church his parents went to a church
his grandparents went to a church we're
not trying to blame a religion nor
should they but it seems like every time
it's connected to a fringe element of
the Muslim community they always try to
connect it back to Islam so they could
have easily connected it back to a
religion but we don't get that happening
here at all now I want you to imagine if
this terrorists would have possibly
let's say eating biriyani or just got
caught walking past the mosque or a
Muslim you get the point and
they would have connected him in any way
possible to being a Muslim what would
have happened even though we know that
this is a criminal crime totally against
Islam and it is a statistical fact that
Muslims do not if you didn't know they
do not commit the most acts of terrorism
domestically or globally it's
statistical it's factual the data is
clear on this you can't argue it Muslims
again do not commit most terrorist acts
or mass shootings but imagine if this
terrorist would have been a Muslim what
do you think would have happened next
let's get your feedback guys keep the
conversation going we can create some
awareness more and more awareness
concerning these events when they come
out pointing out the hypocrisy and the
double standards and to also help
motivate journalists to be more fair and
balanced and to have journalism
integrity when they report on anything
that they're doing keeping it fair and
balanced thank you guys peace be with
you Salaam alaikum